[Music]
back looking shots on the outside
[ __ ] frequent
supreme vision once again how it makes
the cut and a good job is going to an
open spotted you know who will find you
using a towel screen
of course you would be free for free
when you get opportunities like this to
school yeah Luka probit in the lane and
drawing defense lobbing it up through
and finally he's trending towards having
more triple-doubles 92 $79 look in the
paint the look away dish
1 2 3 splashdown Tim Hardaway jr.
penetration
that's Libre right there as well when he
got to Tim Hardaway jr. it's just having
that I of whose Oakland Don chinchilla
[Applause]
a career-high 13 assists Don [ __ ] just
gonna hurt you so twice just trying to
corral them and say
[Applause]
dungeons finding the Sharpshooter
outside Tim Hardaway jr. and down it
goes
[Applause]
Kika who flips it back looking for his
seventh assist and he's got a moment
where his teammates are that's the sign
of a great basketball player he knows
everybody is on it
[Applause]
the corner cleaver same smartly
take a look at Luca into the paint's
behind the back cookie drip only take
away the aygos finds it man yes with two
shots
this is to pull here's Jordan
[Applause]
birdy would be jealous
Luca finds Dorian finney-smith that was
perfect oh my goodness but on a dime
okay sinners to break
[Applause]
really nice fast what's up you guys it's
Taylor Brooks with bleach to report make
sure that you subscribe for more video
content